bonsoir qui m'attaquent conquête et
merci d'être avec nous le président
centrafricain faustin archange touadéra
réélu donc au premier tour c'est pas une
surprise comment accueillez-vous ce
résultat bonsoir tout ce que je peux
vous dire que ce n'est pas une surprise
les centrafricains ont démontré leur
volonté par la voie des urnes ou pour
dire tout simplement que ils sont des
démocrates le président faustin archange
touadéra lors de son premier mandat a
fait un travail très remarquable
ce qui a fait que les centrafricains
millions donné leur confiance en lui
demandant de de prendre encore la
destinée du pays pour le secondaire sauf
que l'opposition et des détracteurs
dénonce des élections truquées ça va
être compliqué d'unifier le pays n'entre
dans ces conditions on pas du tout vous
avez suivi l'ancien président françois
bozizé qui avait demandé aux
centrafricains deux n'est pas allé voter
et laissant trafic est rond au frais
le déplacement dans les différents
bureaux de vote pour remplir leur devoir
civique
ils ont démontré aux yeux de l'opinion
nationale internationale qui sera des
démocrates
donc il n'y a rien à faire malgré la
pression qui avait été faite par
monsieur françois bozizé avec ses amis
du codever veux qu'ils ont tout fait
pour empêcher qu'il y ait les élections
les centrafricains ont décidé d'aller et
s'exprimer je vais vous dire une chose
madame on a remarqué par exemple labo
noir la 2d bambari monsieur alexandre en
guinée a demandé aux autres africains de
cette localité de n'est pas allé voter
ils ont dit niet
ils ont ils sont venus malgré le coup de
feu organisé par la cpc des monsieurs
bouzid et de monsieur bozizé contre le
centrafrique m et son trafic et sont
venus ils ont exprimé
ils ont dit qu'ils doivent soutenir la
transition
la démocratie est une peau jamin être du
côté de la violence
cette violence qui nous a été imposée
par monsieur bronzé avec les mercenaires
qu'il allait introduire à ce trafic qui
aura des victoires et qui constitue
aujourd'hui la cpc ça ne pourra jamais
marcher et la majorité ce trafic un ont
démontré par ces élections que ne
peuvent centrafricain veut la paix le
peuple centrafricain veut le relèvement
de son pays et le peuple centrafricain a
confiance au président touadéra daury
l'erreur des questions de dire qu' il y
aura des clauses par ci par là dans le
même jour dans le même temps plus tôt le
même jour on apprend qu'une enquête vise
l'ancien président bozizé hasard du
calendrier peut-être cela peut mettre le
feu aux poudres selon vous
pas du tout l'ancien président bozizé
lui-même il a rompu le dialogue
alors à partir de ce moment qu'il a
rompu le dialogue
la justice va s'occuper de lui la juste
graphique elle va s'occuper de lui et la
cour pénale internationale va s'occuper
de lui avec ses amis du couple un vin
qui ont cherché par tous les moyens à
empêcher ces élections malheureusement
pour eux ces élections ça s'est bien
déroulé dans la transparence
ils sont trafiqués rondinaud à la
dictature et son trafic en audi no homo
mercenaires et ces trafiquants ont dit
oui à la démocratie alors une y aura
jamais la guerre qui va cette guerre là
que monsieur bozizé avec les mercenaires
de la cpc afin de nous imposer à son
trafic
ça ne marchera pas la défaite ça sera de
leur côté tout simplement parce que le
peuple centrafricain
m et soutient la démocratie et le peuple
centrafricain soutient la politique du
président faustin archange touadéra la
preuve vous avez vu le plus d'impôts
c'est à quoi je dois dire est revenu à
53,92 sont alors la communauté
internationale en tout cas redoute un
embrasement du pays est ce que c'est une
crainte que vous partagez nous nous
savons que nous avons des mercenaires en
centrafrique en ce moment nous avons nos
amis nous avons en france nous avons la
russie nous avons les rwandais nous
avons là musquin qui travaillent avec
nous qui travaillent avec nous dans ce
contexte là il n'y aura pas il n'y aura
pas l'embrasement c'est vrai qu'il ya
des poches de résistance principale
ils sont en train de mener des attaques
asymétriques
mais nous sommes en train de nous
organiser pour les mettre hors d'état de
nuire
afin de reprendre le contrôle total de
la sécurité la sécurité de notre pays
il ya eu la prise de manga the year
cette ville dont qui a été prise par les
rebelles qui occuperait deux tiers du
territoire sont ils selon vous en
position de force cerbère est ce que
vous avez et réussir à les combattre
seul mais tout ce que je peux vous dire
que nous allons les combattre
nous avons des forces amies nous savons
nous avons des forces amies qui sont
venus en centrafrique nous prêter main
forte et nous allons les mettre hors
d'état de nuire
c'est le voeu du peuple centrafricain
parce que le peuple centrafricain ne
veut plus en entendre parler de la
rébellion
je suis navré de voir que un ancien
président de la république qui soutient
officiellement la rébellion
ensuite une des questions qui sont tous
de me poser et de lui poser est-ce qu'il
a pitié du peuple centrafricain
est-ce que la pitié de ce pays demandez
aux mercenaires de venir piller et pays
pendant trois jours
est ce que c'est ça un homme responsable
non les centrafricains vous barrer la
route à tous et aux groupes armés et aux
détracteurs de la république
merci joachim gauck été ministre
conseiller de la présidence
centrafricaine d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france